네 오늘은 강남 빌딩이 가장 거래가
많이 된 노현동 왔습니다
[음악]
논현동은 논고에서 붙여진 이름입니다
그래서 믿기 힘드시겠지만 여기가 다
논밭이 있어요 진짜 산골짝에 있는
논밭이 있는데 이걸 이제 여기가 이제
개발이 됐습니다 이쪽 지역이 특히 좀
언덕길이나 내리막길이 좀 굉장히 많은
곳이에요 그리고 노현동 1동이 2동이
나눠져 있는데 1동 같은 경우에는
여러분들이 잘 아시는 그 영동시장
사건 그니까 예전에 그 백종원
대표님이 여기에 이제 처음에 창업을
했었죠 여기서 진짜 백종원 거리라고
불릴 정도로 백종원 대표님에 관련된
어 그런 프랜차이즈 업체들이 좀
많았는데 요즘엔 다 빠졌습니다 어
그냥 이제 먹자 상권으로 좀 형성이
돼 있는데 외부 사람들이 좀 많이
오는 곳이기도 해요 그래서 여기는
정말 좀 밤에 유동인구가 굉장히 많은
어 그런 상권이라고 보시면 될 거
같고 노년 초로 갈수록 좀 이렇게
상권들이 좀 없어지면서 그다음에 이제
주택가로 좀 많이 형성이 돼
있습니다네 그리고 이제 저기 그
신사역 쪽 그쪽 노유동 같은 경우에는
거기가 또 언덕길이 워낙 심해 가지고
주거 시설이 좀 많이 밀집되어 있고
그다음에 거기 이제 오피스도 좀
많습니다 그래서 뭐 디자인
사무실이라 뭐 이렇게 광고업 이라든지
관련된 업체들이 좀 거기 많이
밀집되어 있으면서 상권보다는 좀
이렇게 주거나 오피스로 좀 많이
밀집되어 있는 곳이라고 보시면 될 거
같고 노년 이동 같은 경우에는 별도의
상권이 있는 곳은 아니에요 어
도산대로 이면이나 뭐 강남구청
바로이면 같은 경우에는 상이 좀 성
돼 있긴 하지만 대부분 다 주거나
오피스로 좀 밀집되어 있는 어 그런
곳이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다 호선
7호선이 있는데 개인적으로 7호선
라인이 되게 오피스 임대하기 좋은 거
같아요 그래서 좌측으로는 거의
부평까지 연결이 돼 있고 우측으로는
거의 노년까지 연결이 돼 있습니다
그래서 직장인들이 딱 좋아할 만한 어
그런 역이라고 좀 보시면 될 거
같아요 노년과 학동역에 이제
대로변에는 가구거리가 있어요 어
여기도 이제 오프라인에서 온라인으로
좀 바뀌면서 예전만치 않은 부분이 좀
있고 그 거기 이면에는 타일이나 뭐
이렇게 세라믹이나 이런 관련된
업체들이 좀 많이 있습니다 번 외기
한데 제가 노현동 총각때 살았어요
거기가 원래 공무원 아파트였습니다
영동 공무원 아파트 여기가 이제 뭐
영동대교 남단 그렇고 영동 아파트도
그렇고 여기 강남구에 보시면은 영동이
단어가 들어가는 공가 많아요 영동이
아는 뜻이 뭐냐면 영등포의 동쪽이라는
뜻입니다 보면은 그 영동의 흔적들이
되게 많거든요 그래서 좀 그런 부분도
어 좀 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다 그래서 투자 사례 좀
설명드릴 건데 어이 건물 같은
경우에는 원래 되게 낡은 건물이었어요
그래서 철물점이 입점에 있었고 정말
90년도에 지어 가지고 건물이 30년
이상 된 건물이었습니다 엘리베이터도
없어서 임대 수익이 많이 안 나오는
건물이었는데 전층 임대 수익률이
월세가 한 12,200 정도 나오는
건물이었어요 근데이 건물을 매입한
다음에 리모델링을 했습니다
엘리베이터도 다시 넣고 리모델링을
하니까 1,200만 원에서 월세가
무려 4,500만 원까지 올랐습니다
그리고 이제이 건물의 가장 큰 장점이
뭐냐면 용적률이 282% 있어요
그래서 원래 이종 일반주거 지역이
용적률이 200% 82% 더 받은
건물입니다 한 면적으로 쳤을 때는
면적이 한 95평 정도 더 지어져
있는 거예요 그래서이 건물은 만약에
신축을 하게 되면 다시 200%
낮춰야 되거든요 그래서 21년도
72억 원에 매입한 다음에 바로 1년
뒤에 172억 원의 매각을 했어요
그래서 무려 시세 차액만 지금
엄청나죠 그래서 단순하게 좀 계산해
보면 72억원에 매입한 다음에
취득세까지 76억 원 리모델링
비용까지 96억 정도 그다음 이제
172억 팔았다고 하면은 시대 차액이
거의 한 7 80억 정도 되는데
여기서 이제 법인으로 매입했어요
그래서 법인세 22% 아지 내고
나서도 시대 차액이 약 한 60억
정도 남습니다 그리고 이분이 매입할
때 대출을 한 거의 60억 정도
받으셨어요 현금 한 30억 중반
정도로 1년 만에 한 60억 정도
시대 차이를 남긴 그런 사례입니다
물론 이거 같은 경우에는 타이밍이
너무 좋았어요서 시기상 너무 좋았고
그 임대도 너무 잘 맞췄던 그런
사례라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다네 그리고 노현동 자체가 앞서
설명드렸지만 언덕길에 내리막길이
많아서 상권이 확장되는데 좀 뭔가
한계가 있습니다 그런 부분을 좀
주의하셔야 되는데 근데 이런 부분을
잘 살릴 수 있는 방법이 있어요
그래서 언덕길 같은 경우에는이 언덕길
부분을 공부상 치하 1층으로 인정받을
수가 있어요 바닥과 지표면을 평균을
내 가지고 1분의 이상이 되면은
요거를 공부상 지하 1층으로 인정받을
수 있습니다 그래서 만약에 이렇게
받을 수 있다라고 하면 건축적으로
굉장한 이득을 볼 수 있어요 그리고
이제 지하 1층 같은 경우에는
용적률에 해당하지 않습니다 이런
부분에 있어서 인정받을 수 있다라고
하면 건물 가치가 완전 좀
달라집니다네 그래서 이런 점 때문에
고객분들도 지하 1층으로 인정받을 수
있는 건물들을 찾으시는 분들이 있어요
만약에 1종 같은 경우에도 용적률이
150% 이렇게 지하 1층으로
인정받을 수 있다라고 하면은이 종보다
더 높게 지을 수도 있어요 땅에
가치가 완전 달라집니다 이렇게
지하층을 인정받을 수 있는지 없는지
알려면 여러분들이 직접 가서 알 수는
없어요네 그리고 공인 중개사도 모르고
약은 누구한테 사서 약사한테 사야
됩니다 이런 부분이 잘 모르시면
건축사 님이랑 손잡고 현장에 가서
물어보셔야 돼요 그래서 건축사님이 딱
보고 1분 이상 된다라고 하면은
건축사님이 판단하실 수 있거든요
그래서 건축사 님이랑 꼭 현장을가
가지고 이게 지하 1층으로 인정 받을
건지 안 받을 건지 확인하시면 좋을
것
같습니다 그래서 노현동 좀 전망을
말씀드리자면 언덕길이나 내리막길이
심하기 때문에 상권 확장되는데
있어서는 제한이 있어요네 그리고 이제
오피스 임대 같은 경우에도 예전 호기
같은 경우에는 진짜 엄청 가파른 언덕
길에도 인대가 들어왔거든요 근데 요즘
같은 경우에는 인대 시장이 좋지 않기
때문에 그런 곳에 있는 건물 같은
경우는 임대가 잘 들어오지 않습니다
만약에 오피스로 임대를 생각하시면 좀
도로라는 뭐 이렇게 주차라인 역과의
거리라는 이런 거를 되게 좀 신중히
분석하실 좀 필요가 있습니다 그리고
이제 노현동 자체가 좀 거래가 많이
되는 이유 중에 하나가 신사동이
청담에 되게 좀 아무래도 거기에 다
사고 싶 요네 근데 이제 가격들이
되게 비쌉니다 근데 상대적으로 노동은
그쪽 지역과 비교해서 되게 그래도 좀
저렴하기 때문에 많은 분들이 좀
접근을 많이 하시는 거 같아요네
그래서 거래량도 좀 많이 되고요
노현동 같은 경우에는 마땅히 그런
호재도 크게 없어요 호재는 없지만
그냥 무난하고 뭐 평균 이상은 하는
어 그런 지역이지 않을까 그렇게 좀
예상을
합니다 어찌됐든 강남구에서 지금
거래가 제일 많이 되는 어 노동을 좀
여러분들한테 설명을 드렸는데 좀
도움이 되셨는지 모르겠습니다 그래서이
영상이 마음에 드셨다면 구독과 좋아요
알림 설정까지 좀 부탁드리고
여러분들이 만약에 좀 궁금해하시는
그런 상권 있다라고 하면은 댓글 남겨
주시면 저희가 좀 한번 기획을 한
다음에 그쪽 지역도 한번 좀 찾아가
보도록 하겠습니다 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요 딩은 비상
[음악]
all I've L so many
times TR to find my
peace